what up space fam golden here from anime
uproar and i'm here today to discuss
aaron and his titan taking note of how
it transformed over time
using info all the way up to the most
recent manga chapter with the final
season now airing i want to drop
more attack on time videos in the near
future so if there is a specific topic
you are burning up to see let me know
what it is in the comments
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
time videos and want to keep them coming
then the best thing you could do
is warhammer smash that like button and
share this video with any attack on
titan fans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos and while you wait for the
next insane chapter to drop
feel free to check out our growing
attack on time playlist where we got
videos about all the titan shifters
the ackermans the titans ranked for
weakest the strongest and much more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all so as we know aaron is
best known for the attack titan which he
inherited from his father grisha yeager
at the same time he inherited the
founding titan from him too but it was
pretty much
dormant at this point because aaron
wasn't a royal blooded eldian
although he wasn't conscious of his
titan actions at first
he learned to control them after
drinking rod reese's bottle labeled
armor
aaron gains the ability to harden his
titan body he can harden the whole thing
or just specific parts of the titan's
body like the fists with hardened fists
he is able to smash
through the armor titan's armor and
combine that with his titan's wrestling
abilities
and by chapter 76 of the manga he is
more than a match for reiner's armored
titan even though aaron has had much
less time to master his own titan
as we know all titans have their own
special abilities like the jaw titan has
its swiftness
its strong jaws and its sharp claws it
would seem that one of the attack
titan's distinguishing abilities
is its incredible strength which makes
it ideal for attacking as mentioned
with hardening he can break through the
armored titan's armor
pretty much making it useless he could
lift a giant boulder even giant for a
titan and carry it all the way to the
wall
another notable feature is his endurance
which again
goes with the idea of attack and also
moving forward that is associated with
the attack titan all the time
in marley aaron transforms into a titan
three times
and is fighting and exerting himself all
the while porco is shocked when he sees
the third transformation
despite transforming into a titan first
he's also the last titan standing
during this attack he also absorbs the
power of the warhammer titan
which we'll get into after we mention
the attack time's most notable feature
and this feature is that the attack
titan can see memories of future attack
titan users
this is why we see the owl aka aaron
krueger
mention mikasai and armin before they
were ever born grisha reveals that the
attack time user
can see the memories of future users
when talking to rhys family before
taking the founding titan power
according to grisha and i quote from
long ago the inheritor of the attack
titan never obeyed others
i know why that is it's been all to
resist the self-righteousness of the
king
end quote then he goes on to say that
the attack titan is capable of knowing
the future
through its future inheritors it was
actually through this ability that aaron
sent specific memories to grisha in
order to push him to take the founding
titan so aaron could inherit it
then if we want to get inception about
it consider this
past aaron could even see future aaron's
memories when past aaron inherited
grisha's memories of future aaron's
memories
hopefully you could follow that but the
main takeaway is that the attack titan
is the
only known one with access to the
memories of future users
and since i'm a huge fan of time
travel-esque things
i absolutely love that they added this
ability into the mix so that's the
attack titan's powers that aaron's titan
possesses next let's look at the
warhammer titan powers it possesses
because the founding titans powers are
actually the last ones to be fully
unlocked as we'll see
the warhammer titan has some especially
cool and versatile powers
as we saw when the tiber used it the
user can encase themselves in a titan
crystal underground while controlling a
connected titan body
in this way the user can fight while
being practically invincible
except of course if the jaw titan is
present because the jaw titan both its
jaws and claws can actually cut through
this titan crystal
then there's the fact that the warhammer
titan has the power to use hardening to
create just about
anything we're talking more complex
weapons like a giant crossbow
or a giant cat or nine tails whip that
can demolish buildings in one swing
and we're also talking more basic
weapons like swords an actual warhammer
where the name comes from and or a lot
of spikes
these spikes can shoot from the ground
or tighten body
and impale enemies this ability can
pretty much turn you into a titan
porcupine
aaron uses the ability to create spikes
a lot during chapter 117
when he has to take on the combined
forces of the jaw titan armored titan
and many more then of course there's
aaron's most powerful titan power the
power of the founding titan
for a long time it was kind of hyped up
as the strongest titan power but aaron
couldn't exercise the power
except for when he made contact with the
royal blood edina for its titan
and then he could briefly command
mindless titans to attack his enemies
it is not until he makes contact with
his royal blooded half-brother zeke
and the first titan emir fritz that he
with amir's consent
gains the ultimate power aaron convinces
emir to stop listening to royal-blooded
aldians by telling her that he'd put an
end to this world that caused amir so
much suffering so
emir no longer a slave chose to lend
aaron's strength
after this aaron can communicate with
all subjects of emir
through the unknown land of the paths
which is pretty much like a different
kind of plane
that only subjects of emir have access
to he releases
all of the colossal titans in the walls
using the founding titan power
and starts the rumbling in order to
protect the people of paradise
who bore and raised him because the
world desires the extinction of the
people of parodies
and won't stop until the last one dies
aaron decides that the titans of the
walls will trample and rumble
all the lands beyond the island until
the lives there are eliminated from this
world
this final titan of aaron that can
actually use the family titan power is
so p
that he doesn't even have to use all of
his powers to destroy the world
as reiner explains the founding titan is
able to control
all titans and subjects of emir as he
sees fit so he could actually make the
opposing titan shifters like reiner
powerless but instead he decides to give
them free will
so they can try to stop him if they want
what we also saw in chapter 135
is that emir fritz herself is now
hanging out on aaron's giant new titan
body
with all of its bones and summoning past
titan shifters
so they can fight against reiner and the
rest the titan bodies are empty
like the warhammer titan they don't
actually have to be piloted so to speak
from the nape
in this way emir can summon not just any
titans but skilled and powerful
titan shifters a countless amount of
them in order to fight anyone who
opposes her and aaron
she summoned zeke's beast titan
effortlessly captured armin
before he could use the colossal titan's
explosion ability with another long
tongue
titan and went on to summon countless
other titans inexhaustibly
we see a bunch of new titan designs like
an alligator titan a fantastic four
thing looking armor titan a reindeer
titan and much
more emir even summons bertolt's
colossal titan
which helps people realize that they
should get off aaron's giant skeletal
titan
asap and by the way in some of these
scenes you could see how aaron's giant
skeletal titan form
even towers above colossal titans which
is crazy to think about
but back to the story reiner mikasa and
the rest get rescued by falco's flying
titan which suggests that perhaps
emir has access to some flying titans of
the past too that we haven't seen yet
but it seems clear now
that if aaron somehow loses this final
battle and they stop him
it is not because aaron lacked the power
to win as reiner mentioned he could stop
them whenever he wanted by using his
powers to control all subjects of emir
if he does lose it's because he decided
to give them free will and a fighting
chance
although even with that they seem
ridiculously outmatched and that is the
full power of aaron's final titan so far
he doesn't even need to absorb the other
titan shifters because as we saw through
emir he can control
all past versions of the nine titans and
use their abilities he is
stronger than the other founding titans
of the rhys family before him could ever
have hoped to be
because he is not limited or weakened by
the 145th king carl fritz's philosophy
with emir he should have vast knowledge
of the past
we discussed his knowledge of the future
as well and beyond all of that
he has more power than i ever imagined
one character actually getting an attack
on titan to say he is godlike right now
in the world of attack on titan
is not an exaggeration in the least in
fact the founding titan users of the
rhys family
were called gods and they only possessed
a fraction of the power
aaron now wields and that is it for this
video about aaron's ultimate and final
titan form
although he only has three of the nine
titans through emir
as i mentioned he actually has access to
all nine powers since he's able to
summon past users of each titan power
and beyond that he can straight up just
control all subjects of emir and the
other titan shifters if he wanted to
who would have thought that our kid
protagonist who wanted to kill all
titans would go on to become the
ultimate titan
who would destroy the rest of the world
obviously we don't know exactly how the
story will wrap up at this point but one
thing's for sure
aaron with amir's help is now the
strongest titan we've ever seen
but anyways thanks for watching if you
did enjoy this video and want to keep
the attack on time videos coming then
the best thing you could do
is warhammer smash that like button and
share this video with any attack on
titan fans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on titan videos
and while you wait for the next insane
chapter to drop feel free to check out
our growing attack on time playlist
where we got videos about all the titan
shifters and their powers
all the ackermans and their powers the
titans ranked for weakest the strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who help
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost i want to thank the patron
of
legend the one acknowledged by lord
tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world
alpha sigma and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop
all clans ingrata the world acquire
respect liam thompson pattay heffa
ruthean
emperor otaku thomas jones spidey life
tinel baked buddhist
tungsten tarkis and denki kaminari and
our pro hero to your patrons the one and
only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp joe stanton very
gucci jessica kayla font alicia actor
bonnie parks xenokami and water the red
haired raven
florian joanne garcia jack watches anime
fat boy games
deadly saint matthew cruz and anthony
schreiber
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon.com
animeopro and becoming a patron today
for as long as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
legendary people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord
where we talk about anime life and of
course thank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you could also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way
if you prefer whichever way you support
us you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you